der mensch verdankt seine sonderstellung
unter den lebewesen seiner großen
lernfähigkeit die digitale revolution
ermöglicht es uns auch wissen von
menschen allerorts zuzugreifen und davon
zu profitieren man kann schon legendären
man kann gitarre lernen
videoschnittprogramm ihren telekinese
krawatten binden warte telekinese lernen
150 tausend klicks pro sind die
bewertungen hey leute heute befassen wir
uns mit der telekinese komischerweise
gibt es im internet relativ wenig
informationen was verwunderlich ist da
man schnell erfolge in dem bereich
erzielen
nichtsdestotrotz es muss ja einen grund
geben warum dieses video so eine gute
bewertung hat habe ich etwas verpasst
können menschen jetzt einfach telekinese
und ich hab's verpennt oder lan
hunderttausende leute einfach müll
das könnt ihr mal wieder spannend werden
dieses video hat tatsächlich mal kein
sponsor aber ladet euch doch gerne meine
app runter die ich in meinem letzten
video programmiert habe die gibt es für
android und mittlerweile sogar für apple
und wird ständig mit updates versorgt
ich bin komplett aus dem häuschen dass
die app schon über 50.000 downloads hat
und auf den pop charts der app stores
ist heute kommt ein update von davos
cape mit dem man sich coole accessoires
und shop kaufen kann
das wort telekinese setzt sich zusammen
aus dem altgriechischen tele also fern
und kinesis also bewegung es handelt
sich hierbei also um nichts geringeres
als objekte mit seinen bloßen gedanken
zu bewegen also magie aber in der szene
nennt man es nicht magie sondern energie
oder um es mit den worten der kommentare
sektion zu sagen das ist keine magie das
ist energie alles ist magie bis man
herausfindet wie es funktioniert dann
ist es wissenschaft und diese
wissenschaft kann man laut den aussagen
von einigen extrem gut bewerteten videos
im internet ganz einfach
und genau das werde ich jetzt tun aber
weil es ihr von den hunderttausenden
klicks und den positiven bewertungen
noch nicht genug überzeugt seid hier
noch ein paar kommentare ich habe es
geschafft 15 minuten hat etwas gedauert
es funktioniert gut ich kann jetzt schon
ein kleines papier hochheben ist eine
erektion auch telekinese schneider aus
eine sehr verbreitete art und telekinese
zu üben ist scheinbar das sogenannte
saville oder privatmann faltet zuerst
ein quadratisches stück papier oder
alufolie zu einer art stehen
anschließend soll man durch bloße
mentale kraft das rad in bewegung
versetzen können indem man seine energie
in die hände konzentriert und von a nach
b durch das rad fließen lässt
ich bin herr schon überrascht dass ich
das ding überhaupt balanciert klinge es
bewegt sich nicht los geht's das ding
reagiert einfach nur noch luft aber ich
denke nicht dass das was man den
chinesen zu tun hat sondern einfach nur
was damit dass du ein dünnes stück folie
einfach von den umwelteinflüssen schon
in bewegung versetzt werden kann die wir
eigentlich überhaupt nicht mitkriegen
allein schon die wärme darunter reicht
aus um das ding zu drehen okay was kann
man noch überprüfen eine weitere art um
die telepathie zu lernen soll es sein
sich ein stück dünner folie zu nehmen
und sich damit vertraut zu machen man
soll die textur fühlen das gewicht
spüren die folie bewegen und an ihr
riechen und ihr zu hören
dann werde ich jetzt mal eins mit der
folie
[Musik]
also hier hat sich einfach nur mal
eindruck bestätigt dass das nur mit luft
zu tun hat und ich kann verstehen dass
das reicht um leute zu überzeugen die
ohnehin schon daran glauben wollen es
gibt aber auch schon mal menschen die
objekte bewegen können die glaskuppel
luftdicht abgeschlossen sind das hier
ist nichts weiter ist als ein video in
dem jemand der welt beweisen möchte dass
er telekinetischen fähigkeiten besitzt
er schließt luftströme aus durch eine
glasschüssel er beweist uns dass sogar
mit einem fön und selbst hier hatte
daran gedacht ein stück papier an zu
bringen welches glas klar belegt der
föhn ist wirklich an er testet an den
magneten und zeigt das stück papier
unter der schüssel kann nicht von außen
beeinflusst werden dann setzt er sich
hin und bringen es mit seinem bloßen
gedanken zum rotieren
der lupenreine beweis ich habe das video
mehrmals ganz gesehen und es ist kein
schnitt und auch kein film trick zu
sehen dass mit den spiegelungen einer
glasschüssel oder sogar einem schatten
darüber zu fälschen wäre ohnehin extrem
beeindruckend aber in 2007 für eine
einzelperson wahrscheinlich unmöglich
keine luft kein magnetismus kein
einziger schnitt im video es ist perfekt
das publikum tobt im applaus telekinese
ist real keine menge empirische beweise
wird dogmatisch engstirnige
wissenschaftliche materialisten
überzeugen welche sich weigern neue
daten zu akzeptieren die ihre
weltanschauung widersprechen aber im
applaus geht eines unter und zwar das
der ersteller des rund 1,1 millionen mal
geklickt videos verzweifelt versucht
jeden darauf aufmerksam zu machen was er
in dem in der video beschreibung
verlinken blogartikel zu sagen hat dort
erklärte nämlich wie ihr das video
gefälscht hat und wie eng ständig
menschen sind und einfach alles glauben
also ist das genau wie wir alle erwartet
haben das video ist gefälscht da ist die
halterin die skeptiker die darauf
beharrt haben das dann schnitt oder
visual effects drin sind sie hatten
recht aber tatsächlich enthält dieses
video keinen einzigen schnitt und auch
keinen einzigen effekt sondern den tisch
mit hohlen beinen durch die luft und
innere der schlüssel zirkuliert wodurch
der kreisel zu bringen gebracht wird
heute glaubt nicht alles was hier im
internet letzte woche habe ich innerhalb
von einer woche eine app entwickelt ihn
in app store gebracht und die hat es
einen brauch platz eins und platz 2 der
epson place search als gebracht macht
gar keinen sind deswegen arbeite ich
natürlich jetzt weiter an der app und
zwar jetzt genau in diesem moment
live-auftritt schaut er gerne mal vorbei
wenn ihr wissen möchte welches video
nächste woche kommt schaut gerne auch
ins köln vorbei da wusste ich schon
vorher ausschnitte aus dem videos bevor
sie auf youtube und dann kommt wenn er
mich auf dieser reise begleiten möchte
abonniert gerne diesen kanal und dann
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder als
gut
[Musik]